what is beautiful
about the human epigenome don't get me
started
so first of all as an engineering feat
the human
epigenome manages the most compact
the most incredible compaction you could
imagine
so every single one of your cells
contains two meters worth of dna and
this is compacted
in a radius which is one thousandth of a
millimeter
that's six orders of magnitude to give
you a sense of scale
it's as if a string as tall as the burj
al khalifa
which is about a kilometer tall was
compacted
into a tiny little ball the size of a
millimeter
and if you put it all together if you
stretch the trillions of cells that we
have we have about
30 trillion cells in your body if you
stretch the dna the two meters worth of
dna in every one of your trillion cells
you would basically reach all the way to
jupiter
a hundred times yeah it's all curled up
in there
it's 30 trillion cells 30 trillion
human body every one of them two meters
worth of dna so
all of that is compacted through the
epigenome
the epigenome basically has the ability
to compact
this massive amount of dna from here to
jupiter 10 times into one human body
into just the nuclei of one human body
and the vast majority of human bodies
not even
these nuclei and that's sort of the
structural part
so so that's the boring part that's the
structural part the functional part
is way more interesting so functionally
what the human epigenome allows you to
do
is basically control the
activity patterns of thousands of genes
so 20 000 genes in your human body every
one of your cells
only needs a few thousand of those but a
different few thousand of those
and the way that your cells remember
what their identity is
is basically driven by the epigenome so
the epigenome is both structural
instead of making this dramatic
compaction and it's also functional
in being able to actually control the
activity patterns
of all your cells now can we draw
a definition distinction between the
genome and the epigenome
again being greek epi means on top of
so the genome is the dna
and the epigenome is anything on top of
the dna
and there's you know three types of
things on top of the dna
the first is chemical modifications on
the dna itself
so we like to think of four bases of the
dna acgt
c has a methyl form which is sometimes
referred to as the fifth base
so methylc takes a different meaning
so in the same way that you have
annotations
in a orchestra score that basically say
whether you should play something softly
or loudly or
space it out or you know interpret
basically the score
the human epigenome allows you to modify
that primary score
so a modified c basically says play this
one softly it's basically a sign of
repression
in a gene regulatory region i love how
you're talking about the function that
emerges
from the epigenome as a musical score
it is in many ways and uh every single
cell plays a different part of that
score
it's like having all of human knowledge
in 23 volumes like 23 giant books which
are your chromosomes
and every single cell has a different
profession
a different role some cells play the
piano
and they're looking at chapter seven
from chromosome 23 and chapter four from
chromosome 2 and so forth
and each of those
pieces are all encoding in the same dna
but what the
epigenome allows you to do is
effectively
conduct the orchestra and sort of
coordinate the pieces
so that every instrument plays only the
things that it needs to play
you